what's up my babies it's episode 174 of
congratulations what'd I tell you dude
what did I [ __ ] tell you man is
different now
it's [ __ ] different now man I let
everybody know it I texted all my
friends it's [ __ ] different dude it
is different all right I got the [ __ ]
bangin podcast I got the special that
came out it's different now and I said I
told [ __ ] Steve Trevino I told a
bunch of [ __ ] comedians I told Eric
Griffin when the [ __ ] pops when the [ __ ]
really pops is when it's different and
I'm [ __ ] dressing differently man I'm
dressing differently I went out to get a
[ __ ] coffee today and somebody said
oh my god I'm sorry I have to stop you I
think you know I love your podcast I
love your stand-up and I thought that's
the final straw dude I'm I'm getting my
[ __ ] Chicago Hope 90s [ __ ] denim
jacket and I'm not wearing a [ __ ]
shirt anymore and I'm putting on these
glasses that are like tint blue green
kinda and I have a chain on because I'm
DMX and it's [ __ ] different dude and
I've said it's different and it's
different and after that [ __ ] girl
with the shaved head came up and said
that to me I was like that's the straw
that broke the [ __ ] camel's back man
that's the straw that broke the camel's
back is different and guess what
everyone knows now everyone knows
because I said it earlier and I set it
up and now this is the [ __ ] way it is
dude so if you're gonna [ __ ] look at
me and act like I'm not gonna be wearing
a [ __ ] Chicago Hope 1990s by the way
swag from the [ __ ] [ __ ] I was in
Chicago hope when I was 16 dude oh you
don't know you do now I was in it dude
okay I went to the [ __ ] rap party
probably dude I it's different it's
absolutely different okay and then and
that was it when you get to the [ __ ]
sea here's the thing I'm not that famous
but when you cross the [ __ ] threshold
into the lower
of Mach 11 nobody could tell you [ __ ]
dude and that's where we are baby the
lower rung of Mach 11 it's different now
and I can't help it and I'm you know
part of me wants to be like I'm sorry
but I'm not because it's just the way
the [ __ ] cookie crumbles do it yes
I'm [ __ ] 15 I realized I'm 15 and
that's how it's gonna be dude
because let me tell you why when you're
a young kid and you want to be the way
you want to be right you just want you
what you want you want ice cream for
dinner dude you want to wake up and eat
a cherry pie your parents are like you
gotta drink some orange juice and you're
like but I want chocolate and your
parents are like you can't drink that
and you're like well what the [ __ ] do I
care I just want it well because when it
in the adult world you have to eat a
breakfast and then eat the dessert
afterwards and then you get older and
you start doing that you start doing
that you become 30 and 32 and then you
start doing that you're like well I got
to eat the [ __ ] meal and then eat the
ice cream but bro that's not the way man
you know what the way is the way you
[ __ ] won you're an adult dude it's
covert season man so [ __ ] eat the
dessert first and that's what I'm doing
the whole thing is getting back to being
that [ __ ] you gotta be who can be the
old man the quickest who can be the old
woman the quickest old men [ __ ] [ __ ]
their pants babies and old men [ __ ]
their pants because they're like look
baby [ __ ] their pants because they don't
know how to walk but all men [ __ ] their
pants cuz like I can't be bothered
that's how you got to get if you can get
like that that's ultimate enlightenment
and that's why this is a [ __ ] cult
dude I waited man I waited for you
[ __ ] Monday wasn't feeling at
Tuesday I was a little bit nauseous and
played it up and I didn't want to do the
[ __ ] podcast but now it's time to do
it man because you don't want me in
podcast mode you don't want me in
podcast mode because that's when the
trouble happens and that's when everyone
realize it's different now I understand
love it or hate it dude
but podcast mode different Chris with
the 90s color pop with no shirt
underneath and the DMX chain
with the Gucci tilt glasses it's
different now I'll sell you drugs
[ __ ]
I mean you know what I mean that's it
man I'm so 90s it's ridiculous I would
never be [ __ ] 2000s i would never be
2010s i was born in 1980 but i'm so 90s
man the 90s [ __ ] consumed me and it
just [ __ ] I became what I became it
was like an abstract painting that you
were looking at trying to figure out and
then you realize by the year 2000 dude
it is what it is there's no [ __ ]
thing it's supposed to be that's me and
I'm getting old I'm getting old before
you [ __ ] man because I'm gonna
do what I want to do I'm gonna do what I
want to do I'm 15 I'm the oldest 15 year
old man that's how it is dude
I'll leave frame I'm not gonna but I'll
leave frame you know you sure there's
oom Zahn I just want to make sure I
can't I can't I can't you know we can't
have [ __ ] one fire and I wouldn't get
rid of their here remotely so I'm
[ __ ] you know I'm doing it all man
but it's it's fine man this is how it is
the world's ending it's you know wear a
mask or don't wear a mask I don't know I
don't know I bring a mask I bring him
ass like I'm a [ __ ] like it's a purse
and I'm like you want me to wear it or
what I don't really give a [ __ ] it's not
that big of a deal but anyway I'm in
podcast mood and that's how we like it
so you know I'm chillin man and it's
been a good [ __ ] week it's been a but
that's you know it's interesting I was
thinking about the moods that you get in
because I was waiting for the right mood
to hit dude to do this podcast I was
waiting for the right mood to hit and I
did a QA room on unfuckin on my podcast
I was doing a Q&A earlier like two hours
ago for UCLA because they were like do
you want to perform at our do you want
to perform stand-up on a zoom and I was
like [ __ ] no and they were like what can
we do a QA and I was like could Chang
Shore do neut I mean and so I did a Q&A
with them and they were asking me all
sorts of questions
and dude they put me in podcast mode and
I was like now is the time to do the
[ __ ] podcast [ __ ] all these schedules
and [ __ ]
I know it's hard you gotta show up for
work you got to do what you got to do
and you got to make the [ __ ] work the
way it works but you know what I mean
for me I have a podcast I just stand up
when I want to I booked the gigs I want
to and I did the podcast when I want to
why am i holding what am i [ __ ] doing
it Monday nights
dude I was doing it [ __ ] Monday in
the day and and and I was always doing
at Monday in the day and then I [ __ ]
I was like why don't what
dude I'm alive at night I'm like mmm one
of those guys that's alive at night you
know what I mean I'm gonna get has real
alive at night I realized that when I
was 22 in Burbank when I [ __ ]
couldn't go to sleep till like 5:00 a.m.
and then I will wake up
I [ __ ] noon but I'm alive at night
man so anyway since I'm alive at night I
was like I'm gonna do my podcast at
night and of course now I started doing
my podcast at night and then I was like
why do I even have to do it Monday night
dude I'm like a you know what I'm like
I'm like the chick that's kind of eating
her way out of the relationship that's
what I'm doing and it's fine dude
because you could still come with me
anyway cuz it's a podcast it's not a
relationship but I'm the girl that like
went to [ __ ] France for two weeks and
then really run it by her boyfriend and
was like oh I bought tickets to France
you didn't know and the boy what the
[ __ ] did it you're going to France why
don't you tell me she's like I don't
know I thought if I if I did it if I
talked to you about it I wouldn't do it
I would check it out so I just bought
the tickets really quickly and I'm gonna
go and the guy was like well okay I
guess that's cool and then what by the
time she comes back
[ __ ] is she's got the [ __ ] Chicago
Hope nineties jacket on with the collar
pop the DMX chain no shirt underneath
and the Gucci took glasses and it's
[ __ ] defferent bro [ __ ] vas
deferens I just thought about vas
deferens that's so weird they call that
[ __ ] that vas deferens they cut your
[ __ ] vas deferens for a vasectomy
dude what man Oh guys were out there
just cutting that [ __ ] that's ridiculous
to do though I couldn't do that vas
deferens s German anyway dude
great great I got water on the mouse and
now the [ __ ] pages are flying all
over the place
that's dude I can't get him on I can't
get him going the pages are flying
everywhere
it looks like the [ __ ] screen in the
Minority Report when Tom Cruise is doing
all this [ __ ] Brod dumb is it that he
had to act that [ __ ] and then they had
to put the [ __ ] in later like well Tom
go ahead and he was like okay and he
would just do this [ __ ] and just and he
did this dude he turned it like this he
thought that was a good idea and the
directors go like this that is a good
idea we'll put in a circular thing in
post
dude Minority Report Wow anyway dude got
the page back got to redownload the ads
yes but it's all good man turned on my
Netflix special man after you watch this
it's no pain or will you go watch a man
on fire or incorrigible or whatever the
[ __ ] I'm also along comedians of the
world but it is it dude it's lit your
boys from New Jersey he's 15 and it's
[ __ ] different dude and I was waiting
I was waiting for today
I was literally waiting for today all of
my life ever since I said it to Eric
Griffin man why do we do it the way we
[ __ ] do it man
we can just do it however we want Kanye
West is out there making shoes that look
like a [ __ ] melted toothbrush
do you know what I mean he's out there
making [ __ ] shoes with holes in them
bro you walk you walk and the water gets
in and [ __ ] are walking out
there with wet feet and they're like
will Kanye says it's okay [ __ ] that dude
I'm done with that [ __ ] I like Yeezys
dude but like they keep coming out the
same color they got Yeezy Abbas is the
new one coming out also he making up
words dude that's the [ __ ] just [ __ ]
what do you call this one a PEZ and then
he goes to sleep that's the whole work
deck for him I'll come up with a shoe
name what is it a bears really dude and
every shoe is the same shoe for real
every color is the same color look at
all of them look at the apes' look at
the [ __ ] the white one the [ __ ]
mint that they're all the same dude
butter cream they all look the same
and [ __ ] are out there just
scooping them up wearing them like
they're different they're not as
different as me dude I got whoo I have a
few you know I've to be honest I have
like six of them and some of them looked
the same but I stopped myself right
there dude I was like no more cuz we're
all suckers deep down in a certain way
we're all suckers you could tell man you
drive by a [ __ ] jack-in-the-box and
you like who would eat there you drive
by it enough you're like I'm really
hungry let me just check it out
the burger looks good by the way I'm
sick of the [ __ ] burger places I know
I've talked about this before but I'll
tell you right now
they asked me at the Q&A on the UCLA
thing they asked me what's the best la
meal and I go like this you know what
man if you're coming to me for a real LA
meal I don't a lot of people eat to live
a lot of people live to eat I don't live
to eat man that [ __ ] is fuel for me put
it in my mouth
I'll eat it it'll be quick and then I'm
about my business all right so I'm about
my business after I eat I'm not [ __ ]
numb them all but really on them them I
don't like I don't go to restaurants if
somebody says they're good whatever I'll
just go if it's near if I like the
ambience you understand all right so
they asked me and I said I'm not about
this [ __ ] in and out dude in and out if
you ask me for a good Los Angeles meal
in and out that's it that's what I'm
thinking and that's what I'm doing and I
love in and out and when people [ __ ]
say by the way Theo put up a thing the
other day about how in him in and out is
not even that good and I just to be
totally interesting right now I
completely disagree with him and that's
that's [ __ ] interesting to disagree
with somebody who has a podcast so he
[ __ ] said that and I go like this
okay all right by myself just alright
okay and I got mad by myself that he
said that and I was like okay alright
whatever dude and then then I was like
well I haven't texted with him in a
while
since the Kovich [ __ ] he jumped out of a
[ __ ] group chat that we were in which
is [ __ ] by the way dude he jumped
who jumps out of a group chat let me
tell you right now if you jump out of a
group chat you're [ __ ] [ __ ] for real
you do you let those dings come in or
you hide it or whatever the [ __ ] you
know how you could [ __ ] whatever you
what do you call them do not diss
or whatever the [ __ ] that's [ __ ] I'm
tracking the group man there's a
[ __ ] in there that doesn't even
write he hasn't written since he's been
in the group chat and he's still
watching and I know he's watching and
sometimes we forget he's there we almost
talk [ __ ] about him but anyway dude no
in and out no way no way in and out is
so good and people like uh but the fries
dude shut up shut up man it's about the
burger you go to a burger place for a
burger okay and then and then people are
like oh yeah but Shake Shack see that's
the thing
they always come around with like some
new [ __ ] and it doesn't have the staying
power that in and out has people like to
say that like the new [ __ ] is better
because they want to be interesting and
I hate that [ __ ] you know
oh but have you heard of oh you like
that ban but have you heard of this man
I saw them play at the place and there
were only 12 people there but they're
the new one Oh bro congratulations the
[ __ ] Lewis and Clark
you found them that just means you were
you stumped you just were there dude
you're bragging about being somewhere
imagine how boring you got to be about
bragging about being somewhere and there
are [ __ ] out there talking
about that what with chain Burger
restaurants they're like yeah but have
you tried Bluebird burger there's always
a new one with blue in it
have you tried Bluebird burger blue blue
stone have you tried blue tapestry have
you tried blue ribbon dude in and out go
guess what we have [ __ ] I just turned
myself up in my headphones that's why
there's a little bit of a cut because
you know this is one take dude this is
just one take and it goes one take and I
don't cut [ __ ] out unless maybe I
[ __ ] talk to someone else or about
someone else and then I asked them if I
could put it in and they say no but I
think that something happened one time
anyway whatever dude foreign on all
cylinders man so yeah so in-and-out is
the best burger and what we what people
people are just they don't want to be
loyal man they don't want to be loyal
dude people [ __ ] hate being loyal and
one of the number one things you ask if
you ask any random person down the
street hey what are your five biggest
qualities
I guarantee number four will be like oh
but and also I'm loyal then what the
[ __ ] are you doing looking for different
burgers dude
when I say in and out is the [ __ ] I go
to in and out I go to in and out I go to
in and out I go to in and out I go to in
and out I go to in and out and then
after a bunch of times I go to in and
out I go to in and out somebody says do
you want to try the new shake and I say
well why don't we stop right there I'm a
loyal [ __ ] I'm going to in and
out but I heard shake check is that's
fine
I tell you what if I'm hungry and I'm
near a Shake Shack or I'm at the airport
and a shake shack is around and I know
there's no in and out I'll get a shake
shot but until then dude I'm in and out
man I'm in enough for life for those of
you doesn't know know in and out isn't
in that as a burger uh but yeah so I'm
loyal dude I'm not ever looking for the
different [ __ ] I figured out what I like
and that's what you got to do it and
people are like ah but it's
narrow-mindedness oh yeah but I already
[ __ ] thought about all the other
things people like well don't you want
to travel what have you never been to
Taiwan is it beautiful and I already
thought about it
ah [ __ ] man I'm not tired yet right I'm
not gonna lose steam dude there was a
[ __ ] you know what's so [ __ ]
ridiculous is all these commercials now
that are socially conscious it's like
it's like dude just cuz we're going
through kovat you don't have to make a
[ __ ] commercial about how socially
distancing is important okay is zouzou
like dude make a goddamn car just
because just because you're practicing
social distancing doesn't mean you can't
remain connected make a car there was a
[ __ ] raw I don't know remember it was
a acura or some [ __ ] in
Finity I think it was dude what what's a
[ __ ] infinity anyway like there's too
many of them I don't know one person
with one and I would never know somebody
with an infinity ever in my life if my
friend had an infinity I go like this oh
I thought I knew you but dude and also
infinity picks like the weird numbers
and letters and [ __ ] it's like a q35
it's like dude what what am i James Bond
it's a [ __ ] rs7 a [ __ ] a7 you do
it out he does it's like Q howdy has a Q
as a matter of fact whatever don't
listen to me but my point is they think
it was infinity and it was like in times
like the dude don't every commercial in
times like these with the time like this
with it we're staying connected is more
important than ever
oh yeah okay Velveeta it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] put it in my mouth it's so
ridiculous it's importantly times
anytime a [ __ ] product is telling me
how important the time is I'm out I'm
out man make the product its commercial
suck hire me I'll be like hey you want
these pants get these [ __ ] pants
these pants are the best pants
I'll trump it up
yeah dude socially conscious commercials
are the worst you just you tried you're
a commercial you're trying to get us to
buy your product why are you being
socially conscious what was the ad where
the really [ __ ] asked one where people
were like I think it was a shaving one
where they were like a shaver one where
they were like it was some [ __ ] like you
don't need to be and it was so
ridiculous was like you don't need to be
a man to shave your beard like all right
dude it was like I can't remember what
it was but it was so [ __ ] pandering
the second I could smell the agenda I'm
out I don't like to smell the [ __ ]
agenda I can't smell
[ __ ] agenda dude during times like
these it's more important than ever how
many commercials have started that that
way during times like these it's more
important than ever to visit living
spaces do you need end tables well
remember we're here for you during times
like these comfortability is more
important than ever we know a lots going
on in the world so here at Radio Shack
come get a [ __ ] VCR hey RadioShack
how do we still exist my buddy [ __ ]
Dean Del Ray has the funniest bit about
RadioShack I don't remember it buddy
you'd be like why is it [ __ ] how is
there still a RadioShack anyway hey come
on come on guys buy this
but during times like these we're more
here for you than any place home depot
they'll do it with home depot like they
give a [ __ ] dude you need wood during
times like these we understand the
[ __ ] structure of society may be
collapsing but we're not Home Depot
during times like these we know it's
going to be awful and you might get
kovat hookers we're here for you when
you thought life sucked we're here to
suck it back hookers slobbing on your
knob hookers hookers one the oldest
profession in the world way older than
Kovac hookers wash your hands also
hookers
just just because it's harder to stay
connected in the real world doesn't mean
it's hard it should be hard to connect
your [ __ ] into a [ __ ] hookers or a
butthole or a mouth hookers
we want you to feel sensation oh [ __ ]
that was so loud in my in my headphones
anyway do it with a mad set whole rhythm
adds that we about to read some ads Hova
insecure jay-z yo we bout to read some
ads she like this outfit yo ma you good
you good
I didn't mean to ask again I was just
making sure um yo you guys tried nutria
fall let me tell you something man in a
time when self care is more important at
a time when self care is more important
than ever
every day is an opportunity to skip
damaging styling tools and chemicals and
focus on better hair growth from within
nutria foal is formulized with potent
botanicals to help you pull mechanicals
to help you grow hair as strong as you
are as strong as you are dude and you're
strong and it's physician formulated to
be 100% drug-free it's got no drugs in
it it's kind of drugs in it nutria fault
is a physician is physician formulated
to be 100% drug-free they use natural
clinically effective botanicals for
better hair growth through whole body
health on top thicker stronger air
without lasers of chemicals nutria Falls
ingredients may also help you get a
handle on better sleep stress skin nails
and boyo yo-yoing libido does it work
yes 77 percent of women saw improvements
in just 90 days you're probably like
yeah but to take 4,000 days no 90 days
you know how many months that is so few
whether you're experiencing thinning
hair or not you deserve hair as
wrong as you are okay neutral four can
help you achieve your best hair growth
naturally I've been taking it and man
somebody walked by me the other day and
they were like are you a chia pet you
can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to neutral
fold calm and using promo code congrats
to get 20% off this is their best offer
available anywhere anywhere man plus
free shipping on every order get 25% off
at neutral fold compliments the best
offer anywhere 20% off at neutral fold
calm spelled n u TR a fol calm promo
code congrats for hair as strong as you
are speaking as strong roman most guys
have tried different ways to last longer
but saying the Pledge of Allegiance in
your head are counting backwards from
ten doesn't exactly work I used to try
to think of the cartoon Calvin AHA's or
do baseball lineups and I would still
sometimes friggin bust nuts early but
the folks at Roman a men's health
company are changing the game with Roman
swipes the secret to longer-lasting sex
Roman swipes are clinically proven to
last longer
they do clinically proven to help you
last longer in bed they're effective
easy to use and fast-acting but don't
require a prescription Roman can ship
swipes to you in discreet unmarked
packaging and each swipes packet is
small enough to hide in your wallet for
wherever for whenever you need it swipes
are great they will not transfer to your
partner so you can last longer without
worrying they're super easy to use just
take swipes out of the pocket swipe it
on let it dry and you're good to go
that's it then commence the horizontal
mambo get $10 off your first order of
swipes and free 2-day shipping I get
Roman comm / babies that's get Roman
dot-com / babies for $10 off and free
today shipping get Roman comm / babies
everybody likes the horizontal mambo
swipe these on you and you can last
longer that was my thing at the end I
didn't tell me to say that part
speaking of shoes dude I was talking
about Yeezy there's too many [ __ ]
[Music]
collabs on shoes it's so annoying now
just have the shoes be the shoes okay
Oh Ben and Jerry's came out with that
[ __ ] ice cream shoe it's so ugly dude
all the patterns they're done we're done
making the good shoes that's the thing
they put you put all these patterns on
they got the cow pattern the blue-green
it's all the chunky monkey [ __ ] and they
comment in a [ __ ] big ice cream tub
are you out of your mind I'm 40 and 40
years olds are scooping that up like
their ice cream man but dude so you know
at least the the what do you call it the
ice cream [ __ ] at least it seemed fun
with it
the ice cream [ __ ] seemed fun with it
ice creams fun shoes are fun if you like
shoes so you collab that [ __ ] you make
it okay it's like it's like I should go
go home
denim jacket but bro national I saw I
swear to god National Geographic shoes
collabed with [ __ ] vans vans and
National Geographic collaborated on a
shoe hey dude you're not Nike vans hey
you're not a [ __ ] adidas the reverse
of dude
the boomerang oh it went back to it came
from man National Geographic vans hey
dude come on
[Music]
that's the [ __ ] start car drive away
oh come on man
vans and National Geographic
collaborated on the [ __ ] shoe get the
[ __ ] out of here National Geographic
just [ __ ] get showing pictures of
people with long necks and all the
[ __ ] bracelets on their neck come on
man
they made a shoe with a wolf on it which
is cool but then in the back it says
[ __ ] National Geographic and it has a
stupid [ __ ] yellow rectangle gave up
when they tried the logo you know guys
just like oh [ __ ] I forgot to do the
National Geographic logo what do you
mean I'll [ __ ] you've got to present
what are you gonna do I don't know and
then saw a [ __ ] rectangle and saw a
yellow and was like I'll just go with
that and then they try he acted smarter
than all of them and then they were like
okay cool it's minimalistic yeah dude
it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] wolf one
and then there's one that just says
National Geographic with the yellow
rectangle okay you know then there's one
with all back issues of National
Geographic on the shoe printed and then
there's one with an ocean on it like
that says National Geographic and then
it has like what are they called the
latitude/longitude somewhere it's that's
probably the where you'd be like where
is that you look it up and it would be
[ __ ] up your ass you'd look it up but
you'd be like where is that you know I
was sucker Ville oh that's some place
called sucker Ville and then there's one
with that with a with a [ __ ] ice
thing Greenland and then how boring are
the guys that tell you oh you know
[ __ ] Greenland is actually one that's
colder than Iceland and Iceland is the
one that has more green than Greenland
how boring are those [ __ ] people a
guy who would say that would be named
Austin and he'd be so big and you'd be
like cool man alright oh really cool so
ugly there's enough with the collabs do
it let's see what people are saying them
gray wolf jams kind of tough though
I just like who likes [ __ ] National
Geographic that much you know National
Geographic was always the thing that was
just there and then it was a channel
when you got in high school and it was I
others as a channel now what happens if
you just turn on every time you turn it
on it'll be like a [ __ ] boar mauling
a [ __ ] poor moose and now they have
goddamn shoes I'm getting all of them
dude I'm getting all of them
this guy this guy [ __ ] telling you
not to get the National Geographic vans
while he's wearing a Chicago Hope denim
jacket and I'll tell you one thing do it
that's cuz I was in the [ __ ] if I was
this wolf I would rock these shoes for
sure these shoes I swear they troll us
with these [ __ ] shoes man Travis
Scott with his [ __ ] 90 bandanas
[ __ ] low dunks dude National
Geographic as a shoe during times like
these we want you to know that walking
the earth is important
National Geographic shoes you're
probably thinking to yourself why and
then you just hear the guy blow his
brains out look at this I'm so sick of
this [ __ ] canceled culture [ __ ]
who's not sick of it by the way who's
not sick of the canceled culture [ __ ]
like who's like looking at people that
got canceled and then is like nah you
don't even give a [ __ ] if the guy seems
like a good guy or not they're trying to
cancel Jimmy Fallon's the nicest guy in
the [ __ ] world
I know because I know him because I have
nob with stars my elbows are warmest
[ __ ] dude I know this [ __ ]
but dude these people know Jimmy Fallon
did black blackface in 2000 he did Chris
Rock alright dude yeah and you know what
I bet Jimmy Fallon feels bad about that
you know why cuz he's a good guy so what
the [ __ ] now we want him out
we want him gone well I don't care yeah
but he's a real family man he's done a
lot for the community I don't give a
[ __ ] you saw what he did 20 years ago
you didn't apologize cause it happened
you apologize because it got caught no
[ __ ] [ __ ] man who the [ __ ] would
apologize if they didn't get caught
oh hey you did hey you did that [ __ ] no
I didn't yeah you did
sorry the [ __ ] apologizes
why the [ __ ] would Jimmy Fallon be like
hey guys everything's been great
I make 90 million dollars a year but
just so you know I did blackface in 2000
and I'm sorry
enn and thenthe Nana yen on a total
intent that they thought they thought
they I'm getting in the car leaving
Denton I entertained thought that
they're a pie about taters face so much
spitting in the [ __ ] freezer like
this and his wife is consoling him he's
crying Jimmy Fallon on a [ __ ] chair
with a noose around his neck and he
jumps drinking Delinda [ __ ] what's
that one sit Ubu sit
good dog
[Music]
I don't do this podcast for you I do it
for me if you want to listen thanks if
not thanks dude enough for everybody I
wouldn't be I won't be I hope you're
[ __ ] listening to this for the first
time because dude I'm 15 and I'm and I'm
young dude and I'm old as [ __ ] in my
youngness and I'm doing what I want to
do dude my dad told me once when I was
like 18 he was like you know your
grandpa did whatever the [ __ ] he wanted
to do my dad my dad did whatever the
[ __ ] he wanted to do he smoked since he
was nine he always ate meat for every
meal and he got [ __ ] and he lived to
be like 80 something and I always
thought that maybe that was a
ketta life and dude maybe it is so I'll
do what I want it's like dude but also
still be a good guy you know yeah but
still be a good guy man still be a good
guy for real I know this is a silly
podcast but you gotta still be a good
guy because here's the deal with the
masks people are like no I'm not wearing
people it's hilarious that the same
people that would say I'll do anything
for this [ __ ] country will be like
you're not telling me to wear a mask oh
that's cool but I'm confused about that
statement and here's the deal if you
don't want to wear a mask
don't worry mask man I'm not Batman I'm
not the guy who's gonna be like but yes
you will be dude whatever man if you
don't want to wear a mask it's your face
fine but if you're gonna be in a
building with a bunch of other people
then guys like me or not like me might
be like you know what I'm not gonna go
in there's too many people okay you saw
what Missouri was doing at the Ozarks
and [ __ ] that bar with all the [ __ ]
guys who look like they worked out in
the 50s were there you know the guys who
look the good those [ __ ] the guys
that look I saw a thing about
bodybuilding that through the years and
it was like a weight lifter in 1910 and
the weight lifter in 2020 and it was
like so different and the guy from 1930
wasn't even buff he was just like
sucking in and doing this and holding
one of those [ __ ] [ __ ] dumbbells
with the big circles and it's just like
dude first of all what were those
dumbbells second of all why did those
guys always have a mustache and third of
all why were they all at the ozark in
that [ __ ] news thing that I was
watching earlier all those guys were
watching and they had awful tattoos and
none of them had masks on and it was
like they were trying to make a point
they were like [ __ ] it get close to me
bro I'll kiss the [ __ ] out of you no
one's telling me wore a mask I'll kiss
it I'll kiss I'm gonna get so close to
my [ __ ] buddy
[ __ ] it man for our country
are you gay nope for our country are you
sucking his dick for our country and
trying to make a point so anyway so
anyway
you know don't wear a mask man like I'm
not gonna be the guy who's like put a
mask on buddy I'm not gonna be that guy
but also I'm not gonna be the guy the
[ __ ] strange [ __ ]
that's like man I feel really
uncomfortable that this [ __ ] is going
around and whether the media made it a
[ __ ] thing or not whether it is real
or it's not as real as we think it is
I'm still nervous
so buddy would you wear a mask for the
meantime I go like this
sure boom mask you know why it's not
that big of a [ __ ] deal dude it's not
that big of a deal to put a [ __ ] mask
on you know but if it's one thing then
it could easily be another thing what
what's gonna happen next I put on a mask
and then the government's gonna have a
bunch of guys on my [ __ ] grass hey
what's up who are you guys oh we were
set by the government we're to [ __ ] your
ass whether you like it or not cuz you
agreed to the mask thing no that's not
what's gonna happen do it
people are so [ __ ] scared man you're
not scared of the [ __ ] dude you're
either scared of Corona or you're scared
of the government like dude just be a
guy with your own opinion man and these
troubles are the [ __ ] people that act
like they're the ones being [ __ ] the
persecuted or whatever [ __ ] he's
the president well they just don't get
see we need to take society back take it
back the president is the guy what are
you talking about that's like LeBron
being like we need to win more
[ __ ] you are a winner we need to
take this back we're tired they're
taking our country from us man the
president is the guy [ __ ] you I'm not
wearing a mask
then you're scared we're a mask you're
scared of Kovan don't wear a mask you're
scared of the government so bring a mask
bring one how many
back pocket like your [ __ ] boy dude I
have it in my back pocket and if I see a
room with a bunch of people that might
look like they're scared of kovat I go
boom i hook it behind my ears and I walk
in and if I don't I breathe freely
[ __ ] are out there trying to
get the co vid okay yeah but you know
it's actually less because the death
rates are all right cool you're
interesting [ __ ] you're talking
to a dude with the Chicago denim jacket
Oh hot as [ __ ] I'm sweating I turned on
the hair I have shorts on and socks and
no shoes this poster that I don't
[ __ ] I changed it and it's over here
as it South by Southwest comedy [ __ ]
poster and I did the South by Southwest
stand up what do you call it [ __ ]
[ __ ] festival festival man anyway I
got that poster a guy said he made it
for us and each one of the guys was
supposed to be one of the comedians in
the thing I don't know which one I am
it's it's very very he took a lot of
liberties with this [ __ ] there's a
cyclops on it and a guy with three eyes
and I got with four eyes and I got like
a sponge with teeth so I don't know who
I'm supposed to be but he he said that I
was one of those and everyone was one of
those guys and I don't know which one I
am but I got it and I said he said dude
I'm gonna send it to you framed and I
said oh cool what's your address I gave
him my address dude and I never got it
and then [ __ ] I swear to God for real
three years later I get a note with this
hey man sorry it took a long time but I
I got it so anyway I hung it up to
[ __ ] is different now though can't find
it you'll sit with me dude I'm not
cutting this part out you guys you'll
sit with me okay
because I want you to sit with me and I
want you to experience what it's like to
look for [ __ ] ads because you keep
clicking out of it here we go I got them
please sit with me fellas and girls
butters don't [ __ ] bark me undies ah
summertime dreaming
these are the days when visions of
sunshine and surf danced through our
heads probably now more than ever as we
collectively mold into our couches but
we got to keep the dream alive me undies
is committed to the cause by keeping you
in a constant stream of uninterrupted
dream inducing undie comfort i love me
undies man they're my favorites either
all I wear to be honest I switch them up
depending on how I feel sometimes I feel
silly so I put on my polar bear ones and
sometimes I feel cool and I just put
zigzags or regular solid colors on how
do you reach this on an uninterrupted
state of comfort you ask whether I'm
with a membership from the undies with
an ombre ship or a membership hmm and
man it's handy this membership imagine
this every month the softest coziest
undies magically appear at your door as
your unda collection grows your laundry
time lessons and and being an adult gets
that much easier I don't say adulting
plus uh whoops plus a membership comes
with site-wide savings early access and
free shipping
oh and zero reasons to ever leave your
house just grab those new undies off the
porch and get right on back to that
summertime dreaming my undies has a
great offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15% off
and free shipping this is a no-brainer
especially because we have a 100%
satisfaction guaranteed to get your 15%
off your first pair free shipping and a
100% satisfaction guarantee go to me on
DS comm / Congrats that's my undies
dot-com / Congrats and if you're a baby
a true baby from this podcast and you
want [ __ ] to be way different go to me
undies I get these and
and join me at the log cabin better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals well there used to
be for me and it used to be stress
anxiety I had trouble sleeping well
check out what better help does it helps
and it will assess your needs to match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist it's awesome you can start
communicating in under 24 hours that's
quick it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online there is a broad
range of expertise in better helps
counsellor network which may not be
locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room plus you
could even chat and text with your
therapist between sessions its way more
discreet than that also so that's great
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
even available so what do you have to
lose visit better help calm / Congrats
and join the over 500,000 half-a-million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month at better health calm /
Congrats
now what we're going to get rid of this
time is at the end of that it says
congratulations listeners listeners get
10% off and one fire because it should
just say congratulations and listeners
get 10% off so fix it for next did I can
sing man it's hot do it I'm gonna be
brutally honest with you guys it's hot
so I put the [ __ ] air conditioning in
between my legs let's see what the post
mates was dude I checked for Paul I got
post mates a while ago and I want to see
where it is cool there's still at the
[ __ ] thing good thing I worded before
the podcast dude I know how to do things
I know he knows how to do things man
people say no don't do it that way
oh he's cooling [ __ ] man he's gonna
[ __ ] cog oh ho he's gonna wear this
jacket dude anyway
hmm I digress let me tell you something
man I got a [ __ ] let me take the
glasses off for this one dude cuz I want
to get real with you and I would not
that I wasn't real with the glasses but
I'm you ever walk out with a [ __ ]
collar up and you're like this is the
way to do with dude and then you look at
your [ __ ] self two hours later in the
mirror out at the [ __ ] bar and it's
all [ __ ] down and open like you look
like a [ __ ] plant from Little Shop of
Horrors
[ __ ] that [ __ ] call or stay up I spray
hairspray my collars anyway do it
I talk about the real issues [ __ ] NPR um
anyway I live in this house dude and
I've lived in this house for a year and
a half two years two years a year and a
half two years I don't know when I moved
in it was in November one of the
November's and I noticed about seven or
eight months ago that there's a light on
in my back yard and I just assumed one
of the dogs handled it whenever I went
to bed or something butters or Cooper or
Sam or a trash dog he's crafty I thought
that maybe in the back of my head I knew
there was a light that was always on in
my back yard
and it's a big light but I always
assumed that it just kind of magically
went out because that's the kind of guy
I am
if something doesn't get done I assume
it got done
because I don't want to do it so it took
me about nine or ten or eleven months
not just seven to understand fully that
there was a light that was on in my
backyard and it was always on and that
in fact the dogs weren't turning it off
and it wasn't just magically turning off
whenever I went to bed okay and uh I
would look for the light switch casually
starting about four or five months ago
before I went to bed but I wouldn't
really look for it like I wouldn't get
my [ __ ] Monica lon you know what I
mean I wouldn't get a treasure map I
would just kind of casually look not
trying to brag the house has lots of
switches I don't know all of them and my
house has no sin crannies maybe there's
switches and some odd places I don't
know
so I would always go to bed to be like
I'll find it later and maybe it's not
even a real light in my head and maybe I
just made it up you know for real I
genuinely didn't have that full thought
of oh there's a light that's on in my
backyard
and it won't go off unless I actually
turn it off so um I casually would start
look I go to bed I be like what is that
light again I thought that switch that
switch goes to that thing and that this
[ __ ] yeah this one still goes to that
one why would it change okay cool yeah
the backyard well I got those lights
installed and in the meantime this turns
that on but this would turn on before
that what does it matter it doesn't
matter it turns on this now this one's
too bright gotta get that ticking down
gotta call the guy after Cove it anyway
whatever I'm gonna go to bed and then
I'd sit in my bed and [ __ ] not fall
asleep because my restless legs were so
bad until I busted so last night I I
decide you know what enough Sanath and
it is if there's one thing about enough
it's enough I'm gonna find this [ __ ]
light switch thing and my girls like
can't we just and I go no this is what's
happening and she's like but it's lit
and I say no come here you see that
light
it's so [ __ ] bright why do we not
know where the switches to turn it off
and she's like it doesn't matter you
know and I say well if that doesn't
matter then nothing matters let's look
at all the switches so I [ __ ] walk
around the house and I'm like a ninja
you know trying to [ __ ] tiptoe the
baby's asleep and I'm [ __ ] looking
for the light switch dude and I can't
find the goddamn light switch to the
[ __ ] light outside now she's like
you're not gonna find it and I'm like oh
yeah I go come with me to the [ __ ]
bathroom we go to the bathroom and
there's a switch that does the fan
there's a switch that lowers the [ __ ]
Oh and you think I'm lying in the panic
room doors okay
sure they go slow but I still have them
the crook will get in he'll do a [ __ ]
run slide and get in but so one goes to
that one goes to the fan and the end
there goes to the [ __ ] light in the
bathroom and one of them doesn't work so
I go like this
I found it so you know this story
doesn't really have an ending but I'm
gonna get the guy to come and make the
[ __ ] sure that thing and then I went
outside to the [ __ ] place where like
the storage is that isn't in my house I
have to walk out of my house to go into
that and I [ __ ] like maybe it's this
one I click that and then the light goes
on and then I can't turn the [ __ ] new
light off I kept trying to hit the
[ __ ] thing so I wouldn't turn off so
I had to go back into the house and go
to another light switch that I know
works the [ __ ] other [ __ ] and turn
that off you can't turn it off because
they're not I can't turn it off is that
boring yeah but it's part of my life and
you have to [ __ ] hear it why are
there [ __ ] big lights in my backyard
where I don't know where the switch is
how could that possibly happen
wouldn't it be right on the inside where
the [ __ ] light is life is hard dude
and you wonder why I want to wear a
[ __ ] jean jacket with no shirt on in
the DMX chain with my [ __ ] glasses
tilted reactivate realness reactivate
real mode with my glasses on dude
how long have I been going 55 nice and
he [ __ ] keeps going have you guys
[ __ ] seen uh first of all let's talk
about this [ __ ] tweet that this girl
did Kate Kelly Kate underscore Kelly
underscore Esquire look I'm 40 I never
knew what Esquire meant and I will never
know what it means if someone explains
to me what Esquire means I'll go like
this ll-look cuz I don't want to know by
now it's the most [ __ ] word of all time
yeah I'm crystal yeah Esquire I'll
really run me over this girl tweets this
rape did not exist among Native Nations
prior to white contact I repeat
prior to white contact before white
contact that's all there was rape was
the prize of invading a city rape was
the video games of before white contact
are you out of your mind
what you think white guys are in just
[ __ ] came in and then we're just like
you know you can just take it and
everyone's like no yeah watch these
[ __ ] idiots dude so sorry that
they're white that they just gotta be
like oh boy
I know I can apologize for [ __ ] [ __ ]
that never happened five minutes for
them so call um yeah dude and they're
trying to get Jimmy Fallon for blackface
dude he's a good guy I'm sure he said if
I ever get caught for some [ __ ] like
that I never did blackface Jesus Christ
I'm [ __ ] sitting here thinking I know
I never have and someone's like Cruz to
lead a black face in [ __ ] in 1994 I'm
gonna go like this this is my apology
I'm gonna go like this
gonna click on and I'm gonna go I'm
sorry and that's what it's gonna be
because I am I am sorry if I've ever
done blackface I never done it but if I
have I'm sorry
cuz it's a [ __ ] stupid thing to do
apologizing thanks for holding me
accountable guys that's one thing that
people say thanks for holding me
accountable what no no the less people
holding me accountable for something the
[ __ ] better dude I have a podcast
sure it's [ __ ] successful donut donut
count me for anything you understand
anyway
are we done saying I'm that [ __ ] yes
I'm not dealing with that anymore not
talked about anymore but stop saying
that
alright um the last thing I want to
[ __ ] talk about is is 90 day fiancé
have you guys seen this [ __ ] show
here's the deal a lot of people watch
this show I'm not gonna say it's bad I
am NOT going to say it's bad because I
don't say things are bad do I want to
watch it not particularly but I turned
it on the other day people want to watch
it great
it's successful good on you I love
success so if you're a reality
television show that's just a beta main
thing I [ __ ] hate reality TV I
[ __ ] hate it
I don't like competitions I don't like
you know what I mean yeah but if he
[ __ ] doesn't bust a nut for 30 days
all right cool that you're just
describing my for me when I was 15
so 90-day fiance is a gangbusters
[ __ ] thing what do you call it
reality show now I don't watch it but I
caught it I was made to watch it and I'm
a [ __ ] and couldn't say no and wanted
to watch The Sopranos
and she said I always watch what I want
to watch I'm 15 dude
so I [ __ ] turn on 90 day fiancé first
of all one of the guys just straight-up
has no neck okay man you know that guy
he's the only guy worth watching on the
show
that guy is killer I like the guy and
he's my friend I've never met him but
just so you know because I've seen the
show
he is my friend now that's how it goes
if he knows it or not I don't give a
[ __ ]
I decided he's my friend and we're very
close okay I like his hair and it's
really banging and he's got a daughter
and his name is that Big Ed is that what
that guy is I don't know anyway yeah
it's Big Ed he's [ __ ] 4 foot 11 and
he's my friend he lied and said he was 5
foot 2 - the [ __ ] girl that he's
flying over from the pill up Philippines
or something like that and she comes
over and she's like I'm 5 foot he's that
great I'm 5 foot I'm she says I'm 5 foot
2 he says off on foot - - and she comes
and he's like oh by the way I'm 411 ok
hey if you're 411 you're also 5 foot 2
ok if you're a man and you're 411 guess
what you're 5 foot 2 you Adhan those
extra three inches isn't gonna make a
girl have to run and get her towel
alright so anyway this is what I'm
trying to say yes of course it's sad 90
day fiancé
it's sad that somebody's like I'm gonna
[ __ ] get married to this person I've
never met or I'm gonna [ __ ] you know
some of the people handle it finally
does a guy who pretends he's not gay
that's like oh you know I I i met this
Russian girl I'm gonna meet her in
Russia and I want to do that and that's
cool and that's fine there's another
girl that's like I have a guy that I
really love in Australia haven't met him
yet but I want to meet him in Australia
that's cool do that [ __ ] [ __ ] link up
man this isn't [ __ ] 1944 anymore go
link up through tinder for real I'm all
for it
I wish you can get an STD through an app
but I'm all for it man you're grown up
man go
but if you think you're in love like in
deep monogamous love with somebody and
want to start a family and share meals
and build with them and and then move in
with them and live with them and be with
them every day and you've never met them
dude your religion and that's the stone
cold hard facts this is NPR now no knock
on anyone's situation no knock on
anyone's income or abilities or whatever
I understand life is hard but the lady
on the show said that she's never
[ __ ] FaceTime with the guy because
his phone is broken and it's been that
way for like a year okay so that's all
I'm saying so as sad as it can be stop
tricking yourself I know what a catfish
is dude you think your boy doesn't know
you think your boy can't sniff it out
you know how many messages I get from
[ __ ] girls with two posts and her
profile pic is her [ __ ] fat ass and
she says let me suck you and I'm like
either dad died early or you're not real
or you're a guy masquerading shut up
your [ __ ] insel butters goddamn it
dude
still barking whoa whoa they're still
barking ellen barkin whoa my dogs are
Ellen Barkin what am I gonna be done I'm
done I'm done dude
but my point is 90-day fiance is dumb
don't put a time limit on it
there's no 90 days anything it's just do
you have a fiance or not okay the whole
[ __ ] what was the other one I saw the
[ __ ] love at first why they doing all
this with love love is hard enough love
is hard enough dude you know how hard it
is to be with somebody and then remain
with them for 40 years I don't even like
myself 20 years ago I gotta like someone
that I'm living with in 20 years are you
out of your [ __ ] mind dude are you
out of your [ __ ] mind
that's it dude I don't like myself 20
years ago I gotta like someone else in
20 years run or take me out thank God
for this podcast during this kovat [ __ ]
man I just want to tell you guys for
real though don't be [ __ ] idiots
number one and number two the truth is
I'm really I am really appreciative of
you guys anybody that's ever listened to
me talk on this podcast or bought a
ticket to a comedy show thank you and I
know you know [ __ ] I'm down for silly
goose time and that's it but also
sometimes a little bit of realness is
gonna peek out you know the window
cracked open a little bit and you get to
see some realness every now and then
yeah I love silly silly goose times but
whoops I left the window open well why
is it so cause up and oh that's the
realness breezing in whoo what is that
it's realness oh my god I think I need a
scarf no no no relax take in the
realness
but it was just a silly goose no no no
shh over your lips
that's the realness and then a tear you
know what I mean
it's what it's the realness it's the
room and then we kiss guy or girl I
don't give a [ __ ]
some guy even if it's a guy are you are
you're gay and I'm just like this time
[Laughter]
imagine two people [ __ ] and only
wearing sunglasses wow dude however I
never thought of that
imagine two people [ __ ] only wearing
sunglasses and blazers and that's it how
have I never thought of that dude that's
so dope rather take me out as I boss
freeze-frame with the [ __ ] splooge up
in the dudes sunglasses just a blazer
busting a nut here we go oh oh run or
take me out Oh rider take me out
that's how went do it haha Radnor take
me out
that's how it goes do it I'm gonna
regret that anyway you guys thank you so
much for listening
congratulations podcast [ __ ] you know
how it goes man episode 112 into time
and we're having a good time man and
that's it and also I spilled I spilled
water so thank you very much you guys I
appreciate you all listening to me and
remember since these sensations
[Music]
i chance in his head dude